as i started questioning okay why i've
been
why do i feel like i need to eat three
meals a day
and how long has this been going on and
where did this come from and and
so as i questioned that it really um we
never ate three meals a day until the
agricultural revolution till companies
and products wanted to sell you
breakfast uh food and there became an
industry around it and then
due to marketing uh you know we were we
we formed these these habits
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about iconoclasm
and soon you'll understand exactly what
that is
meet tony zorg the ceo and founder of
accounting seed
tony is an iconoclast founder and ceo of
technology entrepreneur forbes books
author and cpa for 20 plus
years he embodies iconoclasm the idea of
challenging the prescribed way of doing
things and coming up with a better more
innovative solution
accounting seed the world's first
accounting platform
is disrupting the cloud accounting
industry and has over 1 000 customers
and 14 000 users
and has sustained double-digit growth
for over 10 consecutive years
meet tony tony zork welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from maryland how
are you doing
i'm great michael thank you for having
me excited to be here i'm
i'm really excited to have you here and
you know you're a financial expert for
more than 20 years the founder and ceo
of accounting seed
and most recently the author of
iconoclasm a survival guide
in the post-pandemic economy and the
question has to start with
what is iconoclasm yeah that's
fair enough so an iconoclast is someone
who's the fusion of three things
they're someone who challenges the
existing way of doing things
they design a better way and then they
have the discipline to
execute that design and put it in place
and i you know have kind of hijacked
this
term because i feel like an iconoclast
is different from someone who's just
maybe an
entrepreneur or a philanthropist
um or an inventor and so i do define it
against those other terms but ultimately
it's those three things and i to make
that even simpler
more simple michael i call it challenge
design
execute so it's someone who really
applies this challenge design execute
and lives by it
and so what you know what which part of
your journey leads you
to you know the conviction that you have
and behind the idea of iconoclasm and
and the need to challenge design and
execute in today's world
well the pandemic did
did the same thing i think for me that
it did for a lot of people
which was to stop and just
reflect and think about what is going on
and how crazy is this and
so i started a book i partnered with
forbes to write this book
and i kind of pivoted i was i actually
just started another book and then i
pivoted to
to really this because as after doing
some soul searching
i really um found that i was
you know when you think about uh
the commercial value for you thinking
for yourself
michael there's like next to none
uh there's like next to no value for you
to actually think
for yourself and think independently
because all you know there's a cost to
putting out messages on
the airwaves on social media all these
things
and you know with that there are
corporations trying to sell you products
there's
non-profits trying to get you to donate
to their cause there's politicians
trying to get you
vote to vote a certain way but there's
very
little if none at all
um forces or people out there trying
to get you to think for yourself and
decide what's best for you and i think
the pandemic just revealed this
uh to a t and i decided
that's what i was passionate about and
we need more material for people to
think objectively and think for
themselves and i try to really do that
in this book it's it's this book is more
of a way to think
um and a formula for successful thinking
for
personal as well as business so i would
say you know my authority
is more of being a successful
entrepreneur so i have a lot of
experience there but i use it i use the
same formula to
manage my diet to exercise to manage my
relationships
my marriage all these things so yeah
so so walk me through if a few of the
you know the case studies or the
insights
that that you've been thinking through
as you're thinking about iconoclasm
what what what are some examples in our
in our life or in history that
you know depict the need for for this
independent thought
yeah there's just there's just tons of
them all over
so i think you know one that a real
simple one that
jumps out at me is um diet and what we
eat
right um i was like most americans i was
struggling to
um keep in the weight zone i wanted to
and i was working really hard and trying
to figure that out
and you know i do crossfit i was
i was a competitive gymnast um
you'll see my real career michael now is
i'm i'm a
i was a gymnast turned accounting rapper
i have a rap video
uh that i put out you'll have to take a
look out and put together
i i already did you're already alluding
to the second half of this okay
all right i'm sorry i didn't want to
spoil that for you but
i actually did a backflip in that rap
video which
you know took a lot of effort so it was
cool for me to be able to still do that
but
so anyways i was struggling to stay you
know in
my appropriate weight zone and i finally
um i got a dog like you and i was
noticing the dog i only fed him twice a
day
and i was like why do i need to eat
three times a day like why can this
creature
eat um you know just twice a day and
then as i
as i questioned what you know as i
started questioning okay why
i've been why do i feel like i need to
eat three meals a day
and how long has this been going on and
where did this come from and and
so yeah as i questioned that it really
we never ate three meals a day
until the agricultural revolution until
companies and products wanted to sell
you
breakfast uh food and there became an
industry around it and then
due to marketing uh you know we were we
we formed these these habits
um and then i discovered intermittent
fasting right which is
enormous and so now i eat once a day
and i've had no problem staying in my my
weight zone
just having one one meal a day and i
actually not even hungry during the day
and i've been doing this for about three
or four years
uh but it was not easy to just get into
that i had to kind of wean myself off of
three meals a day right through
different different
fasting techniques but that's just a
small example
of tons of things out there right and
the book's full of these kinds of
examples
at both a corporate level and a personal
level
wow and so the this idea of independent
thought right because what you're
looking what you're describing here is
this idea that we're getting accustomed
to
a lot of these trends and a lot of these
behaviors that
you know they're not necessarily the
right behaviors for us but but we've
been taught that these are the behaviors
that we should be exhibiting and that we
should be
we should be playing with but but you're
saying well if we actually take us
a moment to think more critically about
what we actually are and what we
actually need
then it might differ from from the
normalcy of society
yeah and i think the pandemic to me it
drove me
absolutely crazy how this went down and
how people
reacted to it and so many people
so the opposite of a of an iconoclast
would be a drone
a drone is someone who doesn't think for
themselves and let
and lets other people do the thinking
for them and decision making for them
so with this pandemic it was very clear
um and in the book i kind of go into
that we had a panic attack as a nation
um and not unrightfully so we were
completely unprepared for this
had no plan and with that panic attack
we were left all wondering
uh what should we do what should we do
and and so so many people let others
make that decision
for them versus
you know looking at different media
sources
um looking to make their looking at
these sources as advisors
assessing their own risk
involved and making an informed decision
for themselves what what mattered right
so i go into this in a lot of depth in
the book
so think if we had you know in when i
was growing up i grew up in the midwest
and we had
um you know drills for tornadoes
and on the east coast we have hurricanes
and everything's rated on a one to five
uh scale system right and so like even
in
in you know think of suburban chicago in
the 1970s we have a drill
we'd run out into the hallway we put our
hands behind our necks
we put our necks down and then our
teachers would actually come by and
critique
they're like okay no you're not doing it
that well put your hands more on
here right and then on the east coast we
had drills for hurricanes and have
hurricane evacuation routes and warning
systems and scales of
one to five so nothing for this pandemic
so
so um it was very clear to me that
several people i knew
thought and were treating this as a one
like oh this is nothing
like this is a joke it's not even a real
thing um
and then several were like treating it
like a five like this is the most severe
thing and you going out means you're
you're actually a murderer you're going
to kill people if you go out
and how reckless of you right and and
the truth is
there's probably somewhere in between
and it's different
risks for different people involved and
then when you throw in
things like social distancing and masks
and
you know then the risks start plummeting
right
quickly but but a lot of people just not
looking at all that information deciding
what's best
letting other people make their decision
for me for them
and that's a big impetus is why i wrote
the book is to get out of that
mindset to think make your own decisions
and so when you're looking now you know
i'm as a young entrepreneur i'm
when i'm taking to heart what you're
saying and what i'm taking away from
this
is this idea that you know both as a
leader i need to
empower myself to be cognizant of the
different information sources and make
my and make decisions that
that are right for me that i that i have
full conviction in but i also need to
create an
environment and foster a culture in
which
people that are working with me have the
ability to do so
have the courage to do so have the tools
to do so
and i'm guessing that there's also a big
part in leadership
and enabling people to do so right
absolutely
yeah absolutely michael i mean on a lot
of levels like
you know as um gosh i don't
there's i feel like five things has
jumped in my head on different
directions you know to go with this but
you know the first thing is
um what i do in the book is try to
outline um
what are called dynamics so you know a
paradigm is a belief system that that
something should be
a certain way and it's always based on
some kind of what i
what i've defined as an underlying
dynamic and i dynam
and i a dynamic is like a force in the
marketplace
it could be technology it could be a
belief system it could be science
it could be uh religious it could be
social norms right these are just ex you
know
all the time these dynamics are changing
um and so when an underlying dynamic is
changing but the business model or
operating model or whatever methodology
the model of doing it
is lagging behind then there's the
opportunity for
for that challenge and then there's an
opportunity to do it a better way
and that's why an iconoclast loves
change because it's just
constantly opening up opportunity so
from a leadership perspective
and especially at my company it's a
growing company we just took on a
private equity partner too so we're
you know tripling the staff that those
type of things yeah all
all of the um all of the things
all the reasons why we did things in the
past are now not relevant
so not i can't make all those decisions
on my own as a leader
we have a whole team doing those so they
need to embrace this
idea of asking why why are we doing it
this way what were the
what was the history of this what were
the dynamics that forced us into this
well at the time we couldn't afford this
type of talent well now we can
at the time um we had this type of a
partner now we don't
and all all throughout the organization
and
this is this is just part of the key to
what i call leveling up
and you know and changing for the better
amazing so so now i i have to take you
back
gymnast turned accountant financial
expert
backflip in a rap video how does all
this add up together
yeah no that's a great question so i um
i was actually a competitive gymnast uh
when i was younger um you know
kind of i i retired kind of when i got
to the collegiate level
um but uh i competed pretty heavily
for about seven years and at a at a
national level
um so i've always been able to do
handstands and backflips and those type
of things and still
and still been able to maintain it so i
do them for for fun
for stunts for kind of show-off stuff
yeah most mostly at the beach where it's
sandy
and i can crash um and then
um i got into college and i
decided that i really loved business and
that there were
so many jobs in accounting and i kind of
liked
accounting because it helped me
understand how like wall street worked
and
you know there were a lot of important
decisions being made after this
information and there was a whole way of
preparing it and theory behind it
and i thought it was kind of fun and
then you know all of my friends were
like you want to do accounting
like no one wants to do that if you
really want to do that you should do it
because there's tons of jobs in that
and and of course like i had three job
offers out of college from public
accounting and
and then i got into technology which
again it's a wonderful field to be in
there's just so many opportunities and
ended up creating this company and
um growing it and and whatnot so what
are the
one of the um um as at now kind of
transitioning from
an owner operator to really trying to be
an executive and a leader i was
listening to a
podcast on um being a more succinct and
effective
uh speaker and it was actually uh
challenged
the executives in the podcast to write a
poem about their company
and so i wrote this at poem and and then
i'm like oh you know
actually this is like all of
all a rap is is a poem to a beat i'm
like i could just add a beat to this and
make this a wrap
i'm like i should do this and that would
be really fun right and i'm always
trying to accounting's a little bit
so believe it or not uh michael some
people think accounting is a little
boring which
i don't understand at all i yeah
so some people think it's boring i know
that's crazy so we're always looking at
ways to make it a little more fun and
interesting so i
i i'm claiming to be the first ever
accounting rapper
and then to make this rap we made a rap
video and to make it
fun i did a back flip at the end to have
to kind of have a big
punch so i i i dusted off you know my
shoes got i was very scared to do these
backflips so i started at the beach and
then i came in
and i had to do it in front of a green
screen with
us with a suit on so with a tie and a
shirt on which
believe it or not that was the scariest
thing because when you're doing like a
backflip and a t-shirt
like you can really get full range of
motion and like every little
thing counts right so i was like
terrified
throwing this back flip in front of the
green screen in this in this
tie and shirt and it all worked out
because i was so afraid everyone's gonna
be like
you're 47 years old you shouldn't one be
doing backflips too
in front you're not a really a rapper
either and you know it would all just
come crashing but i
you know i'm here to prove prove them
all wrong michael i
love it i love it okay tony this is this
was just amazing and
an iconic class and i i'm definitely
looking forward to reading the book and
this idea of challenge design execute
you know regardless of of the decision
this ability to have a personal
conviction on what you do and why you do
it
and i'm taking it now as you know to the
entrepreneurial world and as a leader
and as a contributor then to fostering a
good culture in an organization
it sounds like this is something that
that is really important to cultivate
i want to take you back to your
childhood what really fascinated you as
a kid i know that there were numbers and
i guess also gymnast but you know if
you're thinking back to your childhood
what really got you going in the
day-to-day world
well i i was a huge science fiction fan
well as a child and am today in fact i
also
build legos i have a whole lego room at
my house
so my mom is like okay you've ever
changed since you're 10 years old
you want to see star wars movies and
build legos and i'm like yeah i mean
that's like the same thing
so those those were like a a a product
like lego is very engineering focused i
really like that and then
i always just i really love um space and
astronomy and i think like i watch all
these
um all these documentaries on like the
hubble
space telescope and i've like seen
everyone i just love them
because i think it's just fascinating
what what the heck is out there like
what is out there where do we
where are we in this enormous universe
so i think those really fascinated me as
a kid and still
i still think i'm a kid of michael in
fact i might be
regressing because i'm doing stuff as a
a
40 year old that i should have been
doing as a teenager like making rap
videos but
i love it i love it and what inspires
you today
so the pandemic and watching how people
reacted that was an inspiration for the
book and as you're looking at your day
today what what are some things that
really inspire you
i just think in you know friends and
situations um and people
who just want to improve
and level up is so inspiring to me and
overcome
their you know the thing that's holding
them back
you know as a as a leader of a growing
organization i've had this same
kind of formula that has worked
very well which is my job is to find the
thing that's holding the company back
and you know do this iconic last thing
do the challenge design execute
on it and then level up the company and
then once that's done
ask the same question okay what's
holding us back now
and do the same thing over and i've
tried to do that as an individual too
i've been working on things like um
my emotional intelligence and things
like anger
and things like all kinds of stuff right
all the time so i'm always thinking like
what's holding me back as a person
and i feel like other folks that
you know are um
you know can can lead and share in the
book too you find out
everything i've done wrong too all the
stupid things i've done right
which i think is even in in more
impressive to
be able to share your mistakes and what
you know how people can learn from them
because it makes it so much more real
and so i think you know what inspires me
is people who are willing to share what
didn't work for them
and then how they overcame them and and
open
and helping others is is inspiring to me
i love it and what are three words you
would use to describe yourself
well i would say three words that come
to mind i definitely
i think i'm an ambitious guy because i'm
an entrepreneur and i want to keep
growing
this company and and then you know keep
doing things like backflips
so i think that a lot of folks would say
i'm fairly ambitious
i think i'm also very disciplined i
really thrive on that
i use things like being a perfectionist
to help me
stay disciplined um and
uh i think the third thing is adaptable
i think this is the thing i'm actually
do the best is i can adapt
to a new situation very quickly and
enjoy that adaptation enjoy that change
and i say i think so the
the ambition at being adaptable and then
discipline would probably be the three
words i would use
tony thank you so much this is wonderful
i look forward to reading the book
and thank you for taking the time to
share it with me it was great
thank you michael it's great to talk to
you have a great day
you